well hey everybody says haunting mondays
but it's [ __ ] yeah i was gonna say
everybody's like wait is it monday again
okay on monday if you weren't here
yesterday what we decided cause slasher
fred just said i wonder what movie they
were originally going to review well
that's the thing yesterday
when we did um darkness follows
and then it was getting late because we
were having such a good time and i was
like oh we have to pick a movie to do
for tomorrow and tom's like why don't we
just do another haunting episode and
everybody said yeah totally do that
because you know they're way shorter
than a movie and i was like yeah why not
and i was like oh now i have to make
another [ __ ] uh intro but i was like
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna put a haunting
mondays but it's tuesday it's tuesday
this is a bonus this is a bonus haunting
episode which is good because we watch
it this is dark this is fear house fear
house which
has blake been multiply multiply
requested everybody's asked what the
[ __ ] kind of word is that that i'm
making up and i'm very tired i've been
up since 3 30. right
fair house fear house is a good one uh
it probably would have been
if we had start stopped much earlier
it probably would have been um a [ __ ]
godfather two but that's just because
we still gotta do that right and uh
maybe next week and even even tonight
it's gonna we won't have time to get out
of five too we're gonna we're gonna
watch the coma well tonight we gotta
watch coma because that's the movie
that's going up on the movie
retrospective and we have to move we
have to watch that tonight so we can
record it tomorrow
so you know what i mean but godfather
two and godfather three are on the list
okay those are coming soon
those are great movies i remember two
being better than one a lot of people
say that yeah i haven't seen in a long
time though but that's but that's what
it would have been but like i said it
was too late and i was too tired i mean
i think i fell asleep at what like nine
o'clock
ah that's how i'm getting old but like i
said it's like well i fell asleep early
but then like i said i woke up at 3 30
and couldn't go back to sleep so i laid
there for a little while and then at 5
30 i was like [ __ ] it and i just got up
and got made a cup of coffee but uh you
know that's how it goes so yeah fear
house we had several people ask about
this episode now this was actually one
that
uh the people use their own names which
is always helpful
and i found out after when i was doing a
little bit of research about this that
the guy because this one is like a two
this is not a two-parter but it's kind
of like a two-pronged
haunting attack
in the sense that there was like a
family that was there first and then
they were like [ __ ] this place and ran
out of there and then another family
moved in i know there was a couple moved
in no they had a daughter too didn't
they yeah they did yeah and then they
moved in and uh they had some paranormal
experiences happen there as well so it
was like a two family thing so i looked
it up and the first guy
that
had the three kids that stayed in the
house stephen lachance
he is
now okay so i don't know if he started
out as a paranormal investigator and it
just like happened that he like ended up
in a haunted house or
um that he ended up in a haunted house
and then like subsequently went on to
become a paranormal investigator slash
author
at this point he's written several books
like a few of them are about this
haunting case and then i think he wrote
one like in 2019 or something like that
about the roland doe case which if you
don't know is the possession
poltergeist case that the exorcist was
very loosely based on even though it was
a boy not a girl yeah the real case was
[ __ ] much better than the movie
exorcist it was poltergeist
it wasn't it wasn't possession but
poltergeist has elements
in it that look like possession kind of
like an enfield that also looked a
little bit like possession
but uh no he's probably kind of like a
situation like me yeah where i had a
poltergeist experience
me and my family you know my aunt my
uncle
went on only for a couple weeks and
after that i became interested in
paranormal and jenny wrote some books
about it
after interviewing the family so it's
probably a situation like that he saw it
became a believer
researched it he had experience so i
can't become a [ __ ] parapsychologist
become a ghost hunter whatever probably
how it happened
and apparently i mean at least according
to his like about thing like on his
website
uh he's been like on he's on been on
coast to coast and he's been on cnn and
nbc and sci-fi and discovery channel and
[ __ ] like that so like after they did a
haunting episode and i think they did
another show i had it written down here
somewhere he probably saw it first and
then became
you know what i mean a uh [ __ ]
parapsychologist or you know a
paranormal investigator to be a way to
put it i i could do that i'm [ __ ]
ready i've already seen it i know that
that kind of [ __ ] exists i haven't seen
everything i've seen
poltergeist
i've seen bad houses which might be
haunting but real mild nothing happened
to just feelings you know me and other
people
uh out about experience and near-death
experience i know that this [ __ ] happens
so i've seen more than a lot of
parapsychologists have seen and i ain't
trained for it you have just personal
experience in reading and listening to
other cases oh bless you sweetie if
anybody has said you know ross man we
need you there's a [ __ ] poltergeist
case happening and they tell me the
right things i'll be right down there
they if they [ __ ] pot if they've paid
my plane ticket i'll be there
i'll investigate it i'll help you get
the [ __ ] out of that
i'll investigate the [ __ ] out of it
so i know exactly what it's about and
[ __ ] i'm already battle hardened that
[ __ ] could get very scary
seeing a [ __ ] object just [ __ ] fly
at you out of nowhere you know
you got to keep your cool you know but
you're going to lose your cool but
you'll cool back off i mean when i was a
kid i'd freak out for a second and then
shake it off and go back and look at it
being red you see that yeah yeah
we like when npr when that woman from
npr invest [ __ ] not investigated but
interviewed me she's like why didn't you
guys run well we couldn't we were snowed
in
but even if we weren't snowed in
we wouldn't run it was a [ __ ] event
of a lifetime
to see this thing
yeah it could have hurt you but you'd
get scared you'd run from it five
minutes later you'd be back there at the
back of the scene did you see that man
that was [ __ ] weird
well yeah i kind of feel like i'd be
more curious yeah
yeah you're trying to get down to the
bottom of it and it hasn't hurt you yet
and it probably could have
but it hasn't hurt you yet so what the
[ __ ] is how does this work where's this
thing can you communicate with it we
tried you know not really you know it
defied all that
so
yeah that's he was probably a dude like
me i mean i haven't met him but probably
a situation where he saw it and then
became fascinated
and
made made us part-time living out of it
you know
i mean he seemed like an okay dude on
the show yeah oh yeah now this episode
was this is season three
episode one so this is from 2006
and the [ __ ] happened to him in 2001
uh and it's actually in union missouri
so if you want to like look up the [ __ ]
um it's actually called i think they
call it the union screaming house
uh because of some of the manifestations
that were going on there so i think some
other paranormal teams have been there
as well and like i said he's been on
some other shows and everything but the
interesting thing about a haunting like
i said it wasn't entirely about him
there's more than one family there's
more than one family although he kind of
like involved himself with the other
family yeah like the people that
subsequently kind of makes the story
more credible um we're dealing with the
haunting and they kind of [ __ ]
you know they embellish a bit they're
trying to put on a good show but when
they say there's two
families involved in in the case
kind of had a little more weighty you
know you're more witnesses more people
involved it's harder to fake something
like that it's harder to get two
separate families together on some kind
of conspiracy or story it can happen but
it's just harder
yeah so i mean it could happen like okay
for example like if you lived somewhere
and you thought some weird [ __ ] went on
and when another family moved in or
bought the house or they were the next
runners or whatever and you happen to
mention that there was weird [ __ ] going
on then the next people that came in
there could either like
see and hear weird [ __ ] just because of
suggestion or they could be like
and they could like make up a story
they're like hey because you already
laid the groundwork you know what i'm
saying so i don't know how much
interaction
there was between stephen lachance like
the guy that lived there before and the
family that lived there afterward like
prior to them moving in it didn't the
show made it look like there wasn't any
like he had just kind of showed up on
their doorstep it's like hey i used to
live here and
i've been having like we'll get into
like why he went there but that's it's
rare that a that this a second family
goes yeah there's weird [ __ ] going on
here
even ed dunham i know he had done him i
met him
he's local he was his he's from a
haunting and uh haunting in florida his
name of the episode and he was up there
in deltona i've been to that house i saw
it yeah i met ed at his work that's like
20 minutes from where i grew up got him
on my friend's list on facebook and he's
a ex-army ranger batboy he was from 75th
infantry he was not real he's not a
[ __ ] kind of a guy
um big old [ __ ] ranger all right um
he's older now but
he tried to fight the damn
ghost okay
yeah you can't
i know i know where he's coming from you
know i mean but you you can't get
aggressive with something that's
non-physical it's there's nothing to
punch we talked about the other day yeah
it's not there
you can't punch it so right like i said
we're out of options so
he felt he he he told me he said man i
feel helpless there's nothing you could
do
all right it was
you it's not physical you can't [ __ ]
fight it and it frustrated the hell out
of him
but even after he left that house
the people that moved in the house
afterwards evidently had has not
reported anything which that's not
that uncommon
i mean uh i think a lot of the the
haunting in deltona had more to do with
ed i think i think ed gave off enough
energy to activate it like a poltergeist
it might have been a poltergeist but i
wasn't there i didn't see it
well considering i mean if any of this
stuff is actually true and happens the
way that people say that it does
then
it could be that it's not necessarily
just the house or the property or
whatever but it has to be like a
particular
conflation of things yeah usually having
to do with the people that are living in
the house like the way they interact or
something like that like there has to be
some kind of so then like some other
people might move in and
does not see anything the chemistry
isn't right right that's what i mean
either that or it's like so minor that
they don't notice it
i think in ed's case with deltona it
might have been a bad house
um
and then
place was you know what you would call
from star wars [ __ ] terminology the
place was strong with the dark side
and ed goes into there and he's got a
lot of energy a lot of dark side energy
you know being a ranger and he fuels it
and activates it but when he's gone it
goes away
it was just the combination of those two
and he had kids
his kids were with him that's kind of an
additional fuel source prob possibly
this is all theory there's no book on
this it's just patterns
it involves
uh well
people with strong
personalities
people going through puberty
those two
that that tends to be the pattern
if they're going to the wrong place
something weird can happen
i mean but we're just going by the cases
yeah there's no science behind this it's
more like an art form
you can only go by from what people say
and the what limited evidence you have
i've seen it though but it's very
elusive it's not
it's not something that you can [ __ ]
record you can say well hold on although
i take that back because that other girl
from paranormal witness i talked to her
and she recorded a lot of it on her cell
phone that was called what was the name
of that case
i talked to her
she sent me a damn audio file from her
um phone messages
and it just and it was just this [ __ ]
weird voice going to get to get to get
to get to get to kid and that was not in
paranormal witness
get to get to get the kitty kitty kitty
kitty kitty over and over i think it was
called kitty wouldn't it no or something
poltergeist in something or other
and man
yeah i talked to her for a long time i
forgot her name but she wasn't preparing
i haven't talked to her in years
but she convinced me just telling me
everything that happened tried to get
her on the show but she she really
wasn't that interested she was raising a
young kid baby at the time she was real
busy
and she also seemed like seemed like she
wanted me to pay her to come on the show
and i don't really i don't really work
that way you know
uh but i understand she was
hurting for money you know family young
family and she well yeah that's what i
mean
she said well you know i want to be
compensated for my time and i was like
we can't blame her for that i mean you
know because i'd have talked her ear off
for a couple hours i talked to her over
[ __ ] text and [ __ ] phone and [ __ ]
she was
she had me convinced because i'd seen
poltergeist and she's [ __ ] describing
it perfectly
what you feel how you react and
everything
so she sold me on that one
deborah said please tell me it isn't
monday again it's not
dot that i know of do today yeah we just
decided to do another haunting for today
i just didn't bother like making it i
didn't have time to get
uh but she said uh just getting off work
happy to see you guys are on today yeah
i mean we're usually on today but
usually we're talking about a movie so
but today like i said it was it was kind
of late when we
uh you know stopped last night and i was
kind of really really tired because i
hadn't gotten any good sleep so we
didn't really we were too sleepy to like
watch a whole movie so we're like let's
do another haunting because they're
short so you know what i mean and
they're laughing but tom ross paranormal
investigator you could do it yeah that
term though is kind of [ __ ] hokey
i'll make you a business card
but well what what would you what would
you call yourself instead tom ross
it's just the tom tom
yeah it's like invest needs no
introduction like elvis that's call me
ross you know ross has left the building
but now [ __ ] if any paranormal
investigator [ __ ] wanted me to go on
a poltergeist thing and [ __ ] wanted
me to see it and my explanation if
you [ __ ] pay my airfare i'll go
i'll go but you know that's not my main
job i don't really care about that too
much but i wouldn't i would love to see
it again i would love to see i mean we
have talked about doing that if i mean
it would be cool if we had the money
which we don't yeah but if we had the
money to
kind of go to particular places to live
stream from their like haunted places
i'm betting that
99.99 of the places that we go like jack
[ __ ] what happened i'm sure well we
could always go back to [ __ ] mammoth
that's what i'm saying yeah i mean we've
talked about that before but like i said
that would be super if an investigator
ever wanted to go to mammoth we get the
right place i got to find out exactly
because they changed the [ __ ] room
numbers lois gave us the information i
know exactly what i mean we know where
what the place is called i changed the
name in the book so you didn't sue me
but yeah and evidently the numbers on
the chateaus may have changed because i
think they might have torn some of them
down yeah
renovated and stuff yeah but but the one
the the one that i was in when it
started is still there and that and it
would
man i think i think [ __ ] um the vibe
in that place would bring it back
especially if lois was with me in red
but red's dead now
but i'm pretty sure i'd probably get
wigged out and it would come back
yeah see like now i'm curious like i
said it's it was one thing we were
talking about but like yeah i mean we
can't afford it obviously we can't
afford it but if we had the funding if
somebody wanted to do it we could go
then we could go and stay there for like
a week or something yeah and i don't
know who owns the place but it's it's
probably rentable but the thing is it's
math mountain california the prices are
[ __ ] outrageous
well if you were just staying there for
a week or something though i mean yeah
it would be expensive but it's not like
you're moving into the [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah
you could do it for less than a couple
grand probably yeah you could probably
do it for a couple thousand dollars i
imagine i mean for a week how much like
well i spent five days
just like at an airbnb and [ __ ] like
that like in saint augustine and i think
that cost maybe like just under a
thousand like and that was with food and
everything yeah so yeah california
prices though up so it'd probably be
like twice that maybe twice that two
grand a week and then maybe
with airfare yeah i don't know what
airfare is like nowadays because i'm
throwing flown anywhere like for a long
time but you know and i would hate to
rent the wrong place i'd want to be
there on the ground going yeah this is
it this is the one yeah we'd have to
make sure it was the right right yeah
although it would be interesting to see
that even if it wasn't the right one
like if you thought it was the right one
would it still be no i wouldn't know i
would know it had a certain feel to a
[ __ ] place man
and i remember that layout even though
they changed it they made some doors
because we saw pictures of it yeah like
they've renovated it but you still
recognized it right it wasn't that
different i felt like i was back in it i
mean they obviously like you know
updated it and everything but
you said it looked
pretty much it's the same pretty much
the same they added a couple of doors so
you could get into a bathroom without
going through a hallway that's one of
the things that they did
um
they changed like carpeting and and well
i would hope so but it was pretty close
because back in the early years it was
pretty close
or something yeah
it kind of looking at photographs of it
took me back there
yeah i remember we looked
what was weird it wasn't that long ago i
think we looked up pictures of it what
was weird is on the bottom floor it had
two bathrooms right next to each other
and that was because it was a ski lodge
so it was supposed to be that people
could you the people from the bottom
floor
could use the showers in the bathrooms
and not jam them up so they could go out
to the ski slopes
but wes saw that and he was he was like
wow look at that because he didn't see
that before two bathrooms right next to
each other and oh yeah i've never seen a
hallway yeah but there were there were
three bedrooms on the bottom floor
though
so it's just so everybody could get
ready at once yeah well that makes sense
it's just usually they don't put
bathrooms right next to each other right
next to each other but i can see why
they would though because of the
plumbing and all that yeah and all that
business it's kind of why this this
house has bathrooms like white
one right on top of the other one yeah
it's got four bathrooms in here right
yeah
all right so are we talking about fear
house now let's talk about fair house
looks like looks like the crowd
everybody's here go ahead
all right all right um
the house in the episode is evil that's
even super chats are active if you all
want to [ __ ] tip
tip jenny for her [ __ ]
hard work that she does on every show
you can drop it anytime
time the show i'd like to see some flash
bulbs any questions you can drop them in
the chat line you can [ __ ] super chat
us and [ __ ] we'll uh we'll answer
your questions
that's right we've got that's right i'm
passing around collection please
that's what i do that's the hype man i'm
like a flavor flavor thank you very much
thank you camp guy thank you happy
tuesday oh cam guys you get your [ __ ] uh
wait that was camp guy got the shirts
right yeah they just picked them up
yesterday morning okay so i'd be very
surprised they should be there tomorrow
the next day but if they're just going
to georgia so okay thank you yeah
they're staying in the south keeping
them southern shirts
yeah but they picked them up yesterday
okay like about 11 00. probably here
tomorrow the next day
so let's see um
zach says how messed up is it that this
episode is the thing that introduced me
to the concept of cutting
well i kind of well you know i kind of
feel like
well now everybody knows about cutting
but i and i don't even remember how i
first heard about it but
back i mean when this came out back in
2006 maybe a lot of people didn't know
about it because they did have to kind
of like explain what it was
like now you could just say it and
everybody knows what you mean but it's
like back then maybe they didn't i can't
remember this is this is an epic episode
okay it really is like i said it's like
this there's a whole bunch of people
involved it's got it's got memorable
characters too
this is one of the only episodes that
has has a black guy in it
and and the way he's portrayed is
[ __ ] funny and then he really shows
up he shows up he's putting his i ain't
got time for this he basically yeah he
basically said exactly i don't got time
for the time
with his teeth missing yeah yeah i think
his name was emmett right yeah i've got
his name written down yeah it is the
same old thing women are trying to tell
him to [ __ ]
and his wife's white these white women
trying to tell him about ghosts he's
like i got time for that
it's [ __ ] typical [ __ ] you [ __ ] is
crazy yeah and white women crazy i mean
basically yeah but that but you know he
did call him crazy well his wife and his
daughter yeah well
he's seen enough episodes of haunting to
know that white women
white women are [ __ ] crazy
brother knows
they're crazy
just count it like it is dudes think all
ladies are crazy no but there was a
ghost he saw him because then i'm seeing
it i saw it and i believe
we'll see that's what i mean he's being
very dismissive well like yeah yeah
we'll see how this goes i know how it
always works out on a haunting i believe
right now
yeah ghost looking at him at the damn
foot of the bed yeah he saw the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] too yeah and i was just kind of
like see and it's if it died it was been
me yeah i'd have been like god damn it i
[ __ ] told you so brother woke up
calling me crazy all this time brother
woke up and saw that honky kong at the
foot of the bed looking at him like that
and he was like oh i handle white ghost
i'm getting i'm [ __ ] out of here
now i got enough white people in my life
already i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
looking funny
that was like yeah the ultimate white
people yeah dude
people coming at me but no i understand
what you're talking about man that other
show where they had that where the ghost
was uh remember that that black freed
slave oh that's right yes what the [ __ ]
and he's attacking the white because
this is my house and if i saw that [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah this is your house i'm
gonna buy it
this
is your house [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] out of
here
the way he was in this is my house the
[ __ ] they had the damn white contacts
in his eyes that was a good episode too
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
we'll do yeah we'll get to it actually i
can't remember
[Laughter]
you can have the house it's all good
i'll find another house
there's lots of houses yeah but
this is my house yeah yeah yeah
this is your house i gotta go let me
pack it sorry i just remembered was it i
think it was like from an eddie murphy
stand up from a long time ago where he's
talking about how white people will stay
in like haunted houses yeah he's like
yeah he's like black people like as soon
as like andy lahore it's like certainly
heard oh get out he's like oh well bye
too
yeah
he's like we're not [ __ ] around
well that's why it's so great like going
and seeing
horror movies because i used to go see
horror movies at the dollar theater and
the audience was usually about 90
percent uh african-american was about 90
black uh because that was the
neighborhood that it was in
so it was always super fun like going to
see horror movies because they were
absolutely yeah
they were like well they were absolutely
not having it and they're just like what
the [ __ ] like what they're not having
why you feel so [ __ ] stupid like
talking to all the people in the movie
like yeah
criticizing all their decisions yeah it
was like super funny like it depends
usually i don't like people talking
during movies but when it's like a
horror movie a slasher or something it's
like mst yeah it's kind of like mst and
it's just fun and a lot of times the
movies weren't that good so it was like
kind of funny anyway they were all just
kind of like
like audience participation yeah it was
like audience participation so i liked
that very much but uh yeah so
all right so this house is apparently in
uh
union missouri which if you're from
missouri they said i don't remember how
many miles they said but they said it
was west of st louis i don't know 30
miles something like that i don't
remember
so may of 2001 this guy stephen lachance
moves in now he's like a divorced dad i
don't think they said what happened to
his wife i guess she just took off or
whatever but he ended up getting custody
of their three of the three kids so he's
a single dad
now he has three kids uh he's a
corporate trainer or something like that
and the three kids are named eliza
elliott and eli apparently uh they did
interview
they interviewed two of the kids right
that had grown up
because i think when this happened
uh
they were the kids were 13. eliza was
13. eli was 12 and elliot was 11.
uh but this happened like they did the
show i think five years after the events
so they were five years older
so eliza was 18. she was on there for
sure i think eli was on there too was it
eli or elliot i can't remember one of
the boys was on there too
so they're renting this big beautiful
house
now the first thing that happened um and
i will get into because this is one like
i said stephen lachance did write a book
about this actual haunting and he wrote
subsequent uh books after that and he
actually wrote something in 2004
for like a haunting type website where
he actually went into uh what happened
at the haunting so
if i remember like i have notes i have
the notes from the show here and then i
have like the notes that he wrote like
up here so if i remember like the
differences between the two it's
actually pretty similar it seemed like
most of the stuff that happened to him
um
was i mean they portrayed it fairly
accurately on and and if anything they
kind of toned it down a little bit for
the show i feel like okay um so
so the first thing that happened
basically
is that well the first thing they showed
so they rent this house which is like
massive he said they'd been in like an
apartment with three kids like three
teenage kids or preteens which he said
was like a [ __ ] nightmare so they
moved to this big massive house nice
nice and old and everything
so the first thing that happens is he
hangs up a picture on the wall now i
don't remember what the picture was on
the show but he said in real life it was
a picture of like angels or some [ __ ]
like that
so he hangs it up and it keeps like
falling off the wall which doesn't
really seem all that weird at first on
the show i think they just showed it
falling down like twice like he hung it
up and then it fell and he's like okay
and then he hangs it back up and it
falls again and that was the first
physical that was like the first thing
now the thing that he wrote
it seemed like it happened three times
like it did it twice and then he's like
what the [ __ ] and then he hung it back
up and then he said he turned around and
he said he felt like a
like a breeze or a wind or something
like that like on the backs of his
ankles and then
like the picture fell but it was like
behind his feet then so it kind of like
flew across the room at him which i
don't think they really showed that on
the show but he said that's what that's
what really happened it fell behind his
feet and hold on with the scratch well
kinda or of i don't know how far away
from the wall he was like he i couldn't
really tell from what he said right but
it seemed like he turned around like he
felt a breeze at his feet and so like
the thing like
he implied that it like flew off the
wall i'm guessing
um so yeah they didn't really show that
on the show but like they did show the
picture like falling down and like i
said i don't remember if it was angels
on the thing but he seemed to make a
point of like saying that the picture
was angels
so the second thing that happens is he
sends eli and elliot down to the
basement to get some stuff like to get
the hose and stuff like that like in the
thing that he wrote he specified that
they were doing all this yard work and
so he sent the kids out there to get
that because they were real excited
about
oh one thing that he said that they
didn't do on the show he said they moved
in there in summer well he said too that
the lady the landlady that owned the
house that was renting it out
that they had gone there and it was like
an open house so there was a bunch of
people like walking around the house and
you know renting it and everything like
looking to rent it and she called them
and said oh i've chosen you guys to be
in it and he said she was like real
weird like the way she acted like the
way she was showing the house so like it
was almost like a museum and how she had
chosen them to be like i don't know if
that's true or not but like that's what
he said and they didn't really do that
on the show but he said that's how it
was he also said too that even though
they moved in like in the summertime
because it seemed like it was like
shortly before the kids got off school
for the summer he said that the yard
always seemed like it was autumn like
the like the leaves were always falling
and [ __ ] like that so they always had to
like rake them and [ __ ] like that so i
thought that was a little weird that he
mentioned that but yeah so he sends the
kids the boys down in the basement to
get the hose
to get the house yeah send them boys
down to get their house yeah he said the
boys have to get the hose
get the hose down the basement what the
[ __ ] is this okay yeah well
now while they're down in the basement
um i couldn't really determine exactly
what had happened here but uh it seemed
like on the show
that elliot was down there and there was
like a creepy voice that kind of sounded
like it was saying his name like
like that like not like e.t but you know
what i mean so it was kind of like
creepy
and
so he like runs the [ __ ] back up the
stairs and he's like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm
not going down there anymore uh no thank
you now in real life or at least what he
said in his account
he said that the kid ran up the stairs
and legit stood there and peed himself
that he could because he was so scared
they didn't show that on the show
probably because it's not embarrassed
the kid even though i just said it
hey he said it too he said it on his
website so
um and he said basically i don't think
he said that he saw anything but he said
he heard somebody
or it sounded like a big something like
running after him like up the steps
which they kind of showed on the show
too like something was chasing him up
the stairs but they said he was like
terrified like he literally stood there
and beat himself yeah mammoth me and
wesley he was 11 i think and mammoth me
and wesley would try to go up the stairs
we'd go upstairs together
and we'd start running like something
was chasing us and we get the top look
there'd be nothing there it was just a
feeling you had there was something was
behind you but you always had that
feeling in that house con it was weird
yeah
me and wesley wesley would tell me about
you remember that running up the stairs
like there's something behind you yeah
he felt it too
yeah
well that's apparently what this kid
yeah but it was just you couldn't see
anything
it was just a weird yeah i kind of feel
like he didn't really say he'd seen
anything either he just like heard i
guess he heard something like coming
after him and felt something coming
after him like up the basement stairs
and he was like really really scared we
felt it more like something looking at
you staring at your back behind you and
running from it and it got more intense
you're like look
but you couldn't see anything
we were kids you know yeah well 14.
i guess i was 14 or 15. it's weird
yeah it is pretty weird so then like
okay so the next thing that happens is
the kids are all they said well you know
um they were still like moving their
[ __ ] in and
the kids beds weren't in their rooms yet
so a lot of times like the kids would
hang out in the dad's room like just to
watch tv or whatever so they're all in
there
and uh one of them i guess it's elliot
like the youngest one so he gets up to
go down to the bathroom and he says to
his dad hey will you come to the
bathroom with me and he's like what are
you talking about you're 11 years old
like you know nut up or whatever and uh
you know then the other kids obviously
like tease them like oh you scared like
the basement monster and he's like shut
up you guys shut up you know what i mean
so it's that kind of thing but he was
like super super scared and after a
while like they had eliza on there and
she was you know 13 when this happened
she was 18 like on the when they
interviewed her for the show and she's
like he was actually so scared by it
that after a while we felt bad and like
stopped teasing him about it because he
was like clearly very terrified
so elliot uh goes out in the hall to go
to the bathroom and he turns the lights
on
because and it's funny because when we
were watching the show i said don't why
does anybody in horror movies just turn
on the [ __ ] lights instead of like
creeping around in the dark so it's like
scary but he did actually turn the light
on but then they started like kind of
going off and then coming back on and
going off and coming back on i don't
know if that's really happened but
that's they show the show
and then all of a sudden
murder clown murder clown shows up in
the [ __ ] and this is kind of like i
think this is what people remember the
most like from the fear house evil clown
is the murder house it's the murder
clown but the thing about it and we were
okay so we were discussing this we were
watching the show because i said now
technically
and we'll get into this because somebody
did say something about it later
but technically i said now the kid
didn't say he saw a murder clown in the
hall when he was going to the bathroom
right
at the time yeah
but i will note that at the end of the
show his dad stephen
did say did mention
that the kid was seeing clown kids
seeing clowns right because i was doing
but they didn't say it at first and i
was just like wait did the kids see that
or they just throwing a clown in because
clowns are scary one of the reasons why
jenny's saying this is because every
time they show that clown i was like
where are they getting this clown that's
what i'm saying they say anything about
clowns but at the end they clean it up
he said he
the dad says yeah
my son kept seeing this clown so yeah
they just didn't say it at the time when
the clown first appeared so i was like
clown okay that's random so that's on a
haunting a haunting should have cleared
that up early on i didn't know where
they were getting this clown action
because i i was i never really take a
haunting at its word even though i love
the episodes they're
like i said they're better than watching
the amityville horror they're real the
episodes are better than a lot of horror
movies they are um
but sometimes it's not real clear about
uh
about what witnesses are saying and what
kind of liberties uh [ __ ]
uh haunting takes with the story they do
take some liberties
because sometimes you don't know
like you know they'll have one an
interview with the witness and they'll
say something kind of like generic like
it was so scary i had never seen
anything like that in my life but you
don't know like from what part of the
interview that that was taken yeah like
they could have been talking about
something else like not what they were
showing right you know what i mean it's
all like very creative never seen
anything that scary then they show a
damn demon but the guy never said
anything about it he didn't say he saw a
demon so you're like hold on so like
what did he actually see like what was
he actually talking about jenny and i
are trying to approach this rationally
to know what to tell you guys during
this show you know what i mean and even
when i was trying to do a little bit of
just
a little bit of in personal
investigation trying to investigate what
it was they're talking about
it's hard to keep it straight with just
a haunting itself you got to go online
find details
but uh there's still great episodes
though
yeah i mean even if it's all fake
they're still super cool yeah and in
this case
no the kid was saying he kept seeing a
clown yeah they just didn't mention that
until the end because so i was confused
at first because he's going down the
hall to the bathroom and then suddenly
murder clown and then i was just kind of
like wait he didn't nobody said anything
about clowns like why is there randomly
a clown in your upstairs hallway
definitely um you know why a clown of
all things but i mean they kind of
explain it later on so i was like okay
fair enough you probably should have
said that like at the outset but you
know i'll allow it so so basically he
comes like screaming back into the
bedroom as you would
tells his dad that he saw something in
the hall and he's pretty sure it was the
same monster that he saw down in the
basement that scared the [ __ ] out of him
he was going down there to get the hose
then they said two nights after that
they come back from somewhere and come
back home and all of the lights in the
house are on now i think they only
showed this happening one time but in
the account that he wrote in 2004 for
the website he said that happened all
the time he's like they would come home
and and he said after a while like
because at first they were just like he
thought the kids were doing it like man
you [ __ ] kids like why are you
leaving the you know all the lights on
but he's like after a while they started
like deliberately going and turning all
the lights off and then leaving and then
coming up they even called like the
landlady and said hey are you [ __ ]
around in the house and turning like
she's like no man it's not legal for me
to go like poultry
yeah but he said multiple times they
came back home at night and all the
every single light in the house was on
same thing happened at mammoth
[ __ ] we turned all the lights off
left out
came downstairs turned the lights off
went out to the front got into the car
getting ready to leave and red goes look
he points up and the lights are on in
the house we turned them off and lois
said you turned that off yeah we turned
that off
freaked me the [ __ ] out
and then that's when our first time i
saw that blue hazy
kinda
i don't know man blue misty hazy thing
there's just kind of an area in there
little zones of the blue haze weird
i will note that one time i came in here
and um
the light was on
like that light was on yeah um but then
i discovered later on that actually
pookie has been turning the light on
with her nose oh she can turn it on okay
well because she jumps up there and it's
like right next to where her little wall
brush is okay so sometimes she'll be
farting around over there and go boop
yeah
and she'll turn the light off her on so
i've seen her do it before so i was just
kind of like oh okay it's not good
she knows how to do it it's just pokey's
nose she's just turning the lights off
and on like she was laying down next to
me looking at my tablet i was watching
something and i went up there and i
started scrolling and pushing things on
the tablet and she reached out with her
paw went like that [ __ ] and opened up
a damn menu and looked at me went look
what i did
[Laughter]
yeah and then she's like make those men
talk
and a little man talking i'd take my
earbud out and i put it in her ear and
she's like
and she'll smell it and then i'll put it
in her ear and she'll go and then she'll
oh people are watching here she looked
at the screen
and she would press her head into the
[ __ ] thing and then she went
yeah
earlier before we started the show i
know we're getting off on cat talk again
yeah
but i said one thing that she's learned
to do
is she has discovered that her little
fur is exactly the same color as the
bath mat in my bathroom it's gray yeah
so what she's been doing
is i'll get up in the middle of the
night like to go to the bathroom so i go
down the hall from the bedroom into my
bathroom and it's kind of dark in there
so i don't turn all the lights on like i
can see and [ __ ] but you know what i
mean um but it's still kind of dark in
there and i go in there and she'll be
curled up in the middle of the bath mat
like camouflaged and then sometimes like
i'll go to go to the bathroom and then
she'll go
and like scare the crap
so she knows that i can't really see her
and i think she thinks it's funny to
like pretend cause she curls up very
deliberately like in the middle of the
bath mat which is like the same color as
her and she's just kind of like hey
like waiting for me to come in the
bathroom animal animals or something
else man like cats are far more
intelligent than i thought they were
funny she is like scary smart yeah
i can't believe something
yeah she reached out and [ __ ] opened
that damn screen and then looked looked
at me do you see that i said yeah i saw
it and i shut it cookie did that yeah
and earbuds that was fascinating she's
[ __ ] putting her head against the
earbud
looking at those men talking and then
looking back me because i can hear him
wow
because it probably doesn't make sense
when you're a cat just a person
looking at
guys talking you don't hear anything
yeah you got to tell them you know with
the earbud low i can hear it and then
she was like it's the person
you can hear him talking how is he
talking in that little thing she was
smelling it
how's he in there
what a very small man yeah yeah
oh my god
uh well hi there florence florence says
hey you're new to the channel binged
your book reviews subscribed just
recently well welcome to the show
welcome to the show we do all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] on this show
live streaming
book reviews movie reviews true crime
all kinds of fun [ __ ] so i hope you have
a good time here
but yeah we started doing this a little
while back like talking about all these
haunting episodes so okay so where was i
so
yeah so he said multiple times they
would come back home and every single
light in the house was on
um another thing that he said happened a
lot and they showed this on the show
just happening like once or twice
is that the temperature in the house
would like fluctuate wildly like in one
room it would be kind of like hot and
humid and then like you'd go into the
next room and it would be literally be
like 45 degrees and i think they even
showed like on the show
the thermostat like reading 45 degrees
and
then it would like it kind of like lit
up and sparks flew out of it and [ __ ]
like that
and
at this point steven said that he felt
like
he said it felt like an electrical
charge
shooting through his body that's what he
said uh that it felt like
um
what did and i wrote this down because
and but i wrote it down like really
quick so my handwriting is really messy
so it says tickling inside that would
work its way out oh okay i got you
i'm trying to read my own handwriting i
was like scrawling it in the dark like
while i was watching the episode so it's
not like super legible but yeah um yeah
so he said it felt like some kind of
weird like electrical tingling that
would like work its way out he said
that's what he said it felt like
so um at this point too
they show eliza the daughter
and she starts hearing like some weird
[ __ ] in her room so it sounds like
something in her closet
and she kind of is like what the [ __ ] is
that and she thinks maybe it's her
brother's so she goes looking for them
um but they seem to be sleeping so she
gets back in bed actually they're kind
of sleeping in the dad's room so she
gets back in bed and then the closet
door opens by itself and she's just like
yep [ __ ] that noise so then she gets up
and goes in the dad's room and discovers
that the dad and both the sons are
sleeping all in the same bed because the
kids have been like yeah we're not
sleeping in our room either and then
she's like hey can i sleep in here too
i'm like jesus christ how big is this
bed so yeah um and he's just like what
the [ __ ] man can't i can't you sleep
with three [ __ ]
preteens sleeping in my [ __ ] bed
because they're all scared of ghosts so
there's that
so then um steven's dad who is a
contractor like steven asked him to come
over and check the thermostat and is
like why is
one room 45 degrees and the other room
like 85 degrees and what was with the
sparks and all that but the dad like
doesn't really find anything unusual
which you know should not be surprising
because it's apparently supernatural
now uh in the basement they've made like
much out of this but it says in the
basement because you know how like
anthony call the um the narrator like
how he always he has that great like
spooky voice and he can just make like
random [ __ ] and then there were dirty
dishes you know what i mean so it's like
everything sounds like really really
like sinister but um yeah so he says in
the basement they find a butcher shower
and then like he has to explain what
that is because maybe people don't know
but yeah if that's scary i mean it's
come on it's not it's not scary but i
mean yeah like
they killed animals and blood and
everything but it's called groceries
that's what i mean it's like it's just
me it was back then if you eat meat like
you probably shouldn't be scared by that
they were all eating it would be
different if like you went down there
and it's like and then there was like
serial killers scrappy look then that's
scary but it's like yeah butcher shower
not so much a lot of houses a lot of
houses have those but it's just it was
kind of funny the way they tried to make
it
like it's something sinister like if it
was something sinister i'm like no a lot
of houses have those yeah back in those
days you know it's farm houses even
though look at the look at the block it
doesn't like that was ever a farm
um
but no farm houses and houses that were
had
were out in the suburbs you know what i
mean not even suburbs didn't really have
those back in the early 1900s
people were growing pigs and they had
their own cows and
yeah where do you think the meat came
from you know they didn't have
corporations [ __ ]
stocking up supermarkets that wasn't
that wasn't something until after world
war ii 50s you know
so you had to process your own meat
then you had to come in through the
basement and you had to take a shower
because you were all covered with blood
and gore i wasn't that bad you know if
you cleared if you clean deer you can do
it [ __ ] and uh keep everything very
nice and tidy and there's no gore at all
you know [ __ ] it's nice to feel
dressed the deer bring it in [ __ ]
hang him up [ __ ]
pull the skin off of him and start
processing the rear legs and get the
filet off the back of it and [ __ ]
everything else is just bundled up and
you throw it away
and then everything else is just
packaged up
put into servings they didn't have
freezers back then it was ice boxes
so they probably just cured a lot of it
you know easy to do
you can douse it in maple syrup and hang
it up
it'll cure
or salt cook it let it sit and brine
roll it in rock salt
florence said i loved watching a
haunting as a kid i don't think i
remember this episode though but the
killer clowns got me interested yeah
this i kind of feel like this is one of
the iconic ones for specifically because
of that clown
even though he's only in it for like a
second you haven't seen it i mean
it's memorable this is the one where
when you deal with the second family and
you had a
a black dude married to a white woman
and they had a mixed daughter and
there's an iconic [ __ ] uh scene
she's played by a cute little teenage
mixed chick she's sitting on the [ __ ]
front porch talking to her friend on the
phone and sees a baby hanging in a tree
and she
dead baby hanging in the trees she goes
and tells her mom mom comes out and it's
not there she goes i saw a baby in that
tree
well yeah i'm getting to that yeah
[ __ ] yeah
that that's really the the weirdest part
and that kind of stuck with me that one
and that thing in the clown but like i
said because the clown was seemed so
random right yeah the moment
thought the girl was going crazy because
she was cutting herself by that time and
everything
it was you know and seeing dead babies
in the trees
yeah i hate when that happened it had
the umbilical cord and everything they
showed it for a second it looked like an
umbilical cord and a [ __ ] infant
hanging in a tree
i mean it was obviously
yeah it was obviously fake but a real
baby it looked like it didn't look like
an umbilical cord and a baby um do you
it looked like a doll but i couldn't
really tell like if that was an
umbilical cord or if it was just like a
rope or something i thought it was an
umbilical cord maybe i mean you could be
right it was kind of dark yeah um so
yeah so like i said they kind of make
the whole butcher shower thing sound
like kind of ominous one you know it's
really not but okay
um
so okay so one night the three kids
again are in steven's room because they
like to hang out all hang out in there
like watch tv
and steven like kind of goes in the
other room because his dad calls so he's
talking to his dad on the phone like in
the other room and then the door to
steve's room
closes on its own
at that point eliza said she heard
screaming and this was another thing
that they didn't really go into much on
the show but um but stephen lachance
said later like in one of his other
write-ups
that um they heard screaming a lot like
that was one of the main manifestations
so much so that they actually call this
the union screaming house because
there's like screaming coming from it
all the time
so eliza said she heard screaming but
she couldn't tell like
where it was coming from
and then the the closet door starts
shaking and the door to the room like
from the room out into the hallway
starts shaking and then they can't open
it so they're like all freaking out like
the doors like by like banging like
vibrating and [ __ ] like that and they're
all like flipping out
so at this point i guess they're um this
was like too much for them and the you
know the dad comes in and they're just
all like we couldn't get out and it was
like and he heard all the screaming and
[ __ ] too and he's like okay [ __ ] this
place um we're leaving so they basically
like pile out into the car
and uh you know go stay with steve's
parents for a while and
he said i think on the show they said he
didn't go back but he said he did go
back to get some of their [ __ ] but um
all the sleeping but he didn't go back
there by himself because it scared the
[ __ ] out yeah all the sleeping in the
same room that sounds authentic to me
that's what we did at mammoth mountain
[ __ ] once we realized that [ __ ] was
kicked off and stuff was [ __ ] moving
it was poltergeist activity we all slept
in the [ __ ] living room on a damn
[ __ ] fold-out [ __ ] bed
all keeping an eye on one another nobody
wanted to be alone
would you
you got an invisible [ __ ] force that
seems to be kind of hostile
it could hurt you it's not hurting you
but it could it has the strength
you know
well i got the impression from this show
that that's kind of what stephen was
thinking he's like if you could make
because like i said i think they toned
it down a little bit for the show
because he said
because actually i think if i remember
correctly like what he wrote
that there were actually two incidents
that made them like run out the house
like the first one was kind of like this
whole door vibrating and hearing the
scream and they were like [ __ ] that and
they left like for the night or for a
few days but then they came back
and then it was okay for a little while
but then there was like another really
big event like that and he was like yeah
um whatever it is that's in this house
could actually like hurt my kids and i
don't want that to happen so then he's
like okay we're leaving and then they
just left so i think there were actually
two events that aspect of this story
kind of [ __ ]
piqued my attention because you know i
lived it personally
yeah when you think there's something
hostile in the house everybody's
tries to keep everybody else in sight
in the same room
people are afraid to
go downstairs by themselves that kind of
thing you know what i mean somebody you
need to escort and the boy is asking his
dad dad do i get into the bathroom come
with me he's like no i ain't going with
you you know i mean that was like pretty
early on it was early in the [ __ ] like
then later on he's like yeah okay so
they're escorting each other around the
house and that's actually how it goes
well like any other stories [ __ ]
they're not doing that
so
what i said what he said and i don't
think they showed this on the show but
when he went back to the house to get
their stuff like after they fled
um he said he went back but he would
never go back there by himself like he
always took people with him because he'd
like this house scared the [ __ ] out of
him he said i wouldn't go back to
mammoth or [ __ ] i wouldn't go back to
ma'am especially back in those days by
myself hell no
but it transferred from mammoth mountain
to my aunt's house it was all in that
same two-week period
you couldn't run from it it'd follow you
but you know it's just weird
so after they leave uh the house goes up
on them it doesn't really go on the
market because it's not for sale they
were just renting it so the lady that
owned it put it back on the market for
rent and a new family moves in now this
family is and i'm assuming these are
their real names because they showed
their faces uh was linda marsh and her
husband emmett bryson and they had a
daughter ashley who at the time was 13
years old
now linda said that the house felt
perfectly normal and comfortable at
first and everything was totally fine
um the first thing that happened is
linda is by herself in the house and
she's kind of like you know painting and
decorating doing all that [ __ ] you do
like when you move in
and she hears something or somebody
moving around upstairs
uh which kind of wigs her out i don't
know why i wrote this particular thing
down i guess because i i wrote neighbor
brings pie
and i was well maybe because i love pie
no because i remember i said to you i
was like i wish a neighbor would bring
me pie
i've never because i've never had a
neighbor bring me pie in my whole entire
life and it was a key lime pie too and
i'm like damn [ __ ] somebody needs to
like step up and bring me a key live bye
but yeah or lemon meringue would be
better key lime's good bill emma prank
is better but i just i don't know why i
wrote that down but i wrote a name from
ray spy uh so yeah so she hears some
like [ __ ]
moving around upstairs and like thinks
it's weird
now later that night the daughter ashley
she hears a bunch of like banging around
like in the hall like somebody is
running up and down the halls like kind
of like slamming doors that's what she
thinks that it sounds like
so she comes down and you know her mom
and dad are in the kitchen you know
talking or whatever and she's like were
you guys just upstairs like slamming all
the [ __ ] doors and they're like no we
thought that was you and she's like uh
yeah i think this shit's haunted at
which point emmett the husband uh
basically said and this i think this is
pretty much a direct quote i don't have
time for that yeah i don't have time
that's a perfect that's pretty much what
he says that's exactly what he said i'm
not even like i'm not even i'm not even
kidding exactly
danny goes face caught her [ __ ] mr
jack-o-lantern because his teeth missing
but yeah he had like two or three
jackets right
yeah i got time for that he was a funny
dude though yeah he's funny he's crazy
white women when they're ghosts all
right got tired for that
yeah and he basically just said he's
like i told him dave was crazy he's
crazy yeah i don't have time for that
because of course he didn't see anything
well okay look
there's more to the story
before he said that he says you're gonna
be messing around and waking up things
that don't know that was later later on
yeah it was later on but he he didn't
think
i know the personality type
he probably was weirded out by the house
okay but he was in denial
there's a lot of guys there's a certain
pattern
where yeah they're creeped out by the
house but they don't want to admit it
and then if you keep questioning they'll
think well if you give it attention
it'll get stronger
yeah but there's something to that
actually that might be true
might be some kind of an instinctive
reaction to ignore it you gotta be all
right you give it attention it gets
stronger well yeah we talked about that
yesterday and you think that that might
be kind of like um
uh maybe a factor of the dudes because
they know they can't do anything about
it they can't punch it they can't punch
it they can't they can't do anything
they can't fix it so it's like well
we're just going to allow we're going to
pretend that it's not we're going to
deny it much easier right and it'll get
weaker and weaken it by not paying
attention to it yeah don't let it
dictate
terms
xanada said i've never seen an episode
of the show ever but it's funny
listening to you guys talking about man
you gotta see these things man no these
are good these are good they're good a
lot of them are super good yeah
you can buy them on dvd or you can see
them on amazon a haunting season one two
season one through six
really yeah because this episode's from
season three yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
they're worth watching they're better
they're better than most horror movies
zack said uh there's a haunting app i
remember where they go back for a phone
charger and the ghost makes [ __ ] go off
and i'm like can you not get one at a
gas station for like a dollar
ninety-nine
that's yeah that's what i'm saying it's
like some of the [ __ ] that's in your
house
yeah you know if you think a ghost is
gonna like wing a [ __ ] brick at your
head you don't need the [ __ ] you're like
you can buy other [ __ ] it's fine you
know what i mean it's not it's not worth
risking your life over but yeah so
basically he hasn't seen anything
but
uh the mom and the daughter have seen
some stuff and he's just like you both
crazy i'm just like not having it
now interestingly stephen lachance the
guy that had been renting the house
previously
he said that he kept having like
recurring nightmares about the house
like he kept having like the same one
all the time almost like it was trying
to like tell him something
so he decides maybe these dreams are
telling me i need to go like talk to the
people that live there like to see what
the [ __ ] going on like maybe they're
in trouble
so he shows up on their doorstep
apparently and it's like hey i know this
is like weird and all but i used to live
here and uh pretty sure oh thanks pretty
sure this shit's haunted so have you
been having any uh
problems with the paranormal um you know
what i mean uh emmett basically is just
kind of like i was laughing because um
danny rowling said the black father
black jack-o'-lantern
black o'lantern probably thought stephen
was trying to cut him out with his wife
always coming to her aid and [ __ ] i
actually kind of thought that while i
was watching the show there was a big
age difference between him though though
there was he was much older no she was a
lot older yeah yeah somebody said uh
sebastian said i ordered three on sunday
january time i think it was sunday i
don't know what you're talking about you
can't
you have to give us contacts you ordered
what three shirts
i don't know
yeah if you did like tell me because
i don't remember like when was that
sunday i don't know okay
there's not enough context yeah
uh danny rowling said is it paranormal
to always wake up at 3am just to go to
the bathroom uh if it is then i'm also
paranormal because i do that pretty much
every actually last night i think i fell
asleep at nine o'clock
because i was exhausted i was watching
riff tracks and i was just like
and then um i said but i woke up at
midnight to go to the bathroom and i
woke up at 3 30 to go to the bathroom
and i couldn't go back to sleep so i
just got up no xanada i [ __ ]
challenge you man [ __ ] stream amazon
probably has it do they
um
maybe you can buy well okay
when i search each episode it says that
you can watch them for free on to be and
or pluto okay with ads but i'm not
entirely sure if that's true i think you
might be able to buy whole seasons yeah
on amazon you can usually do that amazon
usually has most of those guys just
choose whatever service you want she
said to be might have them for free with
ads maybe i'm not sure or pluto but no
watch season one you'll like it
every episode is i would say better than
amityville horror
yeah i mean like it's kind of like
creepy horse i don't know there's just
something about them
really comforting they're well made they
got a good soundtracks they even sell
the soundtracks and the scores to them
not soundtrack score they sell the
scores each season has its own cd yeah
or like itunes playlist that has like
all of the music from it because the
music's so iconic and they just
take uh cases that are built
built around
actual witness testimony they say that
they happened and they'll enter they'll
they kind of engineer a good little 45
minute case uh movie around it and it's
it's got
voiceover and you know [ __ ] narration
but it's just it's just classy they're
they're classy the first six seasons are
really good uh the other seasons are not
quite as good but they're still good
yeah they're still good
block frog said wait what i had no no
idea the music had albums yeah yeah i
didn't know that either well the music's
first um but then yeah but then i looked
it up and i was just kind of like every
season i don't know if every season but
all of the early seasons each season has
like a cd and like an itunes thing that
you can buy that has all of the music
from that because each i didn't realize
this but
you know and i know it has like the
theme song and all that like wood that
kind of thing but each um
episode also has its own kind of like
score in the background which is kind of
like a little bit different yeah um so
yeah they'll they put out like a cd and
a an itunes thing for each season like
well at least the early season and to
most of the k most of the stories
there's something to them
there may have been some exaggeration
there may have been some [ __ ] eliminated
you got to do your own investigation to
find the truth but haunting did a good a
good job with both of them okay at least
they tell the story in the entertaining
way
yeah even if it's [ __ ] even if it's
still usually fun to watch and creepy
yeah and it's based around a story
somebody told this they claimed that
they saw it some are better than others
you be the judge you do your own
investigation
zack said my roommate and i use used to
use a site called dopebox to watch shows
for free and a haunting and all 11
seasons are on there just use a real
good ad blocker because man is that site
ad crazy okay there's 11 seasons
i thought that was 12 actually damn was
this on discovery we haven't seen it i
think it started out on did it start as
a discovery or and then it went to
destination america i think it was on
destination see we keep saying that
we're gonna watch the newer seasons i
think we watched them up to season eight
when they're seven
seven or eight but then i think
we saw like some episodes in some of the
later season i think i've seen some of
the 10 and 11 yeah it's like i think we
saw them like on tv randomly like
because sometimes when we used to like
have cable and we used to watch cable
like sometimes it'd be on so we would
watch it yeah but and i was like oh i
haven't seen this episode or whatever
and i think sometimes i dvr'd some of
them yeah but that was a while back so i
don't really remember
so okay so where was i all right
so steven shows up at the house and is
basically like hey you still live here
and uh shit's on it and have you been
having any weird [ __ ] happen because
i've been having like some dreams about
it and i think they're telling me to
like come here and see what's going on
uh emmett is like not having it he don't
want to hear it um i wrote that in big
letters but linda is happy because she
kind of feels vindicated she's like yeah
there is some weird ass [ __ ] going it's
like thank god you're here because
you know this [ __ ] doesn't
believe me um but you know you lived
here and you experienced it yeah it was
it eventually ended up on discovery
the sebastian said sorry yes three
shirts okay which ones did you get
though
where's my pen yeah
we didn't we didn't see the i mean
whatever it was i didn't write it down
which is unusual for me because usually
i write stuff down but some but
sometimes i'll make them up for you oh
thank you got another size just just
tell me just tell me what the sizes and
the shirts are because what shirt it is
and then or if you sent me a message
tell me where you sent the message
because
uh because i have to look for it because
there's a million places like that you
must have payment somewhere we don't
have it that's what i'm saying right
so yeah we'll figure it out yeah
um and then after that i wrote in really
big letters because like i said i was
writing this down like really quickly
while i was watching it i wrote in big
letters emmett won't move and don't
believe in this nonsense i wrote that
one really big
um so
yeah
so at this point like steven basically
because linda's like yeah i've been like
hearing some weird [ __ ] too although i
think at this point all she had really
heard she just heard somebody it's just
sounded like somebody like walking
around like somebody moving around the
house which like it's you know i admit
that's creepy but
you know she hadn't had anybody like
like i said like wing a brick at her
head or anything like that she knows
narrators 81 now
is he really yeah that's what he did he
didn't look the funny thing about it is
that this always happens every time that
i hear like narrators with super cool
voices like somebody whether they're on
podcast or whether it's that guy or
whatever um i always have like a pretty
clear image of what they look like in my
head and i'm always a hundred percent
completely wrong yeah i didn't know that
dude was in his 70s back in those days
he never looks anything like i think
he's gonna look i don't know why he's
one now
he's got a [ __ ] cool ass voice
he makes everything sound creepy well he
does become reality he doesn't just do
um a haunting he does some true crime
shows too okay
well because
do you remember like i think we
mentioned this on a couple episodes of a
haunting like though i think the last
one we did like where the tv came on by
itself yeah and i think one of the shows
that was on when the ghost was going
through the channels was a true crime
show yeah that anthony call also
narrates is it cold case files
maybe
it might be cold case files yeah zanna
to start with season one because i love
that [ __ ] you want to start with season
one i mean maybe you'll think it's
cheesy it is kind of cheesy it is yeah
but it's it's television programs but i
like that they're good they're good i
like that start when you start with
season one episode one you go through it
and you [ __ ] relax and watch the [ __ ]
and [ __ ] trip out now i don't why
whatever i don't like
like paranormal investigators like ghost
uh hunters and all that kind of now i do
like ghost brothers because those dudes
are like funny i don't even think that's
still on anywhere but they were supposed
to be funny that's what i mean but i
don't like ghost hunters and stuff like
that because to me that's just like
boring i'm just like that's a bunch of
like douchey people like hanging out in
an abandoned mental hospital that was 99
green screen yeah going did you hear
that yeah no i didn't hear that it was
90s that wasn't anything it was like
2000's reality tv if you're gonna tell
me a ghost story just tell me a [ __ ]
ghost story yeah don't like just make me
sit in an empty room in the dark
listening to some sounds that aren't
happening okay so i'm just like show me
some ghosts start off with [ __ ]
season one and i think episode two i
think it might be haunting a summer win
that's my best that's my favorite one
haunting summer when it was [ __ ]
weird
zach says apparently tony call the guy
that narrated was on the original
starstruck and twilight zone back in the
60s doesn't yeah i'm going to have to
look that up i didn't hold it okay i'm
going to write that bucket was legend
i'm gonna write that down because
i had no idea because we have watched
the original star trek i love the
original star trek and i love the
original twilight zone and i've watched
all of them multiple times and i didn't
remember hearing that voice but
you know there's a lot of episodes so
it's possible i could have missed it
but i'm going to check that out now
because now i'm intrigued yeah danny
[ __ ] gives you some good advice and
he says start with [ __ ] a haunting in
connecticut and the georgia those are
like the pilots those are the pilots and
they're kind of like movie length yeah
they're movie length and they're harder
to find that you could probably rent
them on on
on um on amazon
but it's like movie length it's got
haunting in connect georgia and haunting
in connecticut
and uh those were the pilots and then go
on to season one
okay so all right where was i all right
so like i said i'm trying to read my
yeah on my scrolls
all right so at this point so like i
said so stephen had showed up at the
house and he's like okay well my advice
to you is
probably you should move
uh he's like because
when we left like the whatever it was is
making the whole house shake and he made
the assumption which you know probably
true that if it can make the whole house
shake then it can probably hurt you
and so you might want to get out before
it gets any worse
so then uh we go to uh
something that tom already brought up
where ashley the daughter
she's had like some weird [ __ ] happen
too but you know like i said she heard
all the door slamming and [ __ ] but so
she's out on the porch
talking on the phone
and she's basically saying to her friend
um you know i've had all this weird [ __ ]
happen in the house but you know my dad
doesn't believe me and it's like he just
thinks me and my mom are crazy and it's
like you know it's very upsetting which
i can imagine
so she's talking on the phone to her
friend and she hears like this creaking
sound and she's outside like she's
sitting on the porch like looking out in
the yard
and she sees what appears to be a dead
baby i don't they don't really specify
because obviously like on the show it's
a doll they're not gonna hang a real
dead baby in the tree for christ's sake
but so i don't really know if she saw
a doll hanging in the tree or
a literal dead baby like a ghost dead
baby like hanging in the tree i'm not
really sure they didn't like because
they didn't interview her and she didn't
like say exactly what she saw they just
showed like what she apparently saw
so there's a dead baby hanging there
from the tree
and she's like what the [ __ ] and then
she's like uh
i love how like kind of [ __ ] she was
wigged out obviously but basically she's
talking to her friend and she sees the
[ __ ] and she's like
i'm gonna call you back and i was like
i just left my ass off i'm like man
she's cool as a cucumber she's basically
like i i gotta call you back i'm seeing
a ghost dead baby like hang from the
tree just uh i'll get back to you
so here's the crazy thing and i this
made me laugh i don't know why but so
the mom comes out
on the porch
and she says mom i just legit saw a dead
baby like hanging in the tree like while
i was talking on the phone which i was
telling you about earlier that's what
i'm saying yeah and
well it's i was just telling them i said
i thought it was so funny that basically
she sees a dead baby hang from the tree
and she says to her friend i'm just
gonna call you back i was just like wow
that's like that's pretty that's pretty
slick so so yeah
so the mom comes out and she's like mom
i just saw a dead baby hanging from the
tree and basically the moms even though
the mom has seen paranormal [ __ ]
happen
previously yeah the first thing she
jumps to
is are you on drugs
are you on drugs
give me some but no
so i wrote down uh ashley's hopped up on
the goofballs like her mom even though
she had seen paranormal stuff happen
she legitimately just the first thing
she jumps to is like oh well you
couldn't possibly have seen anything
supernatural that you must be on drugs
and ashley's like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm not on drugs but i
don't know if she was on drugs it was an
extra large
i guess snake pliskin oh okay and uh 2
13 o'clock i got two different 13
o'clocks okay wait we can talk about i
got one of them with me and jenny on it
and another one with the logo
and i got two different um
snake plastics got with the little image
and a bigger probably the big one is
better probably what he wants yeah i
like the little image makes me look
bigger put that [ __ ] on my chest the
water
extra large he doesn't need tom wants
bigger titties yeah it makes my titties
look bigger
um but no i got two different 13
o'clocks
so if you want two different ones like
is it like the grim reaper one or
uh you know what a lot of people i think
on one of my shows yeah on one of the
shows i wore my old one that i made
remember the old one that i made that
looked like the friday the 13th poster
like i used the same like font and like
the broken glass yeah i don't have it i
don't have the yeah that's the thing
like somebody said oh man i want that
shirt and i was like we don't i mean we
could make another screen though i still
have the image they don't sell much
though what i have is i have the clock
and i have the one with me and you on it
okay it's got jenny's titties on it
you'd love it she's [ __ ] grabbing
titties and then a little more well like
not like
it's not real it's not real graphic but
it's it's little not the whole
yeah i'm just very very small just like
just like the men in your
in your earbuds
would not be funny if she thought they
were tiny people living in your earbuds
or in the tv well children think that
kind of well that's what i'm saying so
that's like really cute because i kind
of feel like feel like pookie has
probably like the same yeah level of
awareness as a child yeah so she
probably thinks there's little tiny
people living in your earbuds which i
think is like that's adorable
so so yeah
so basically mom is like
which i i mean the poor kid she's just
like look i'm seeing like supernatural
[ __ ] and
dad's already like not believing me so
that's i've already written that off but
now mom who has also seen paranormal
stuff is just like are you wearing drugs
what the [ __ ] so she's that's she's
probably like freaking out now she but
she does find out and i don't know like
what the exact timeline on this was but
linda finds out that ashley has also
been skipping school
uh because she's just like school's lame
everybody's lame i was like well i was
like wait till you get older and find
out that yeah most people are actually
lame then you just have to like learn to
deal with it at some point but yeah so
she's been skipping school and we find
out as zach
alluded to earlier ashley is also a
cutter they had to explain
what it was on this show so we were
wondering earlier on in case you weren't
here
um
when did
cutting
become like
when did that become like well known
like what people knew that was
was it yeah because i heard about it
like on i remember hearing about geraldo
yeah maybe i remember hearing about it
maybe in the late 80s early 90s 86 86.
he's like look at these weird-ass people
doing this kind of [ __ ] yeah that sounds
like some [ __ ] there that's a 86 87
thing but even in 2006 when the show
came out when they when they discovered
that ashley is a cutter
uh they have to explain to the audience
what that is so they're assuming that
maybe like a proportional audience
didn't know what that was
they you know felt the need to explain
it
so you knew that look she turned up your
book look at all the [ __ ] little
pieces of paper she's been doing that
like forever but like i said that's why
i deliberately put like really really
old shitty books on the bottom because i
know that she's going to tear them up
and eat the paper she loves to eat paper
i don't know why well she loves to eat
everything pretty much misbehaves she's
like a little goat
but yeah so she finds out too that
like i said ashley's a cutter so her mom
actually puts her in a hospital
uh you know
and linda even then they interviewed
linda on the show and she looks good i
have to say she looks completely
different than like the actors playing
her but you know that happens sometimes
sometimes they get
a like an actor that looks very similar
to the person
and then sometimes it's like wildly
different and sometimes it's confusing
because i'm like that person doesn't
look anything like the actor that's
playing them but yeah so the woman they
got to play linda doesn't look anything
like but the real linda says she like
she basically said she thought ashley
was possessed which okay they didn't
really like go too much more into that
sebastian if it's if both shirts are for
you i'll give you one each man i can
make you one each you like the other one
it says 13 o'clock and it's got jenny
and a little round circle like that with
their [ __ ] hands in her boots and
then me and the other you'd like it
that's good i mean we could just like
give them like one of each one yeah
that's what i'm saying we'll give you
one each yeah because honestly i really
like kind of the clock one with the grim
rupert thing on it yeah i should
probably do another it doesn't have a
grand reaper on does it well yeah on the
top i didn't notice yeah it's like a
little grim reaper with like with a
little hood oh
that one
ravens yeah oh yeah okay that's what
he's talking about i thought he was
talking about the one that looks like
the clock with the round one okay oh
yeah that's right i forgot about it
we've got that one yeah we have a bunch
of them i got three 13 o'clock shirts
okay yeah i forgot we had like three
like i said we used to have an old one
that looked like the friday the 13th
poster yeah that's gone that's gone but
he's talking about the round one oh okay
i think i have a round one and i also
have like a [ __ ] long one that looks
like it looks like an old grandfather
kind of looks like a grandfather clock
or i have another one that says 13
o'clock it's got me and jenny in little
bubbles
that's like the that's the og one that's
the og one that was one of the first
ones we made that was like our old logo
um okay
so at this point i guess
um
emmett the skeptical husband
he says okay you can bring in a
paranormal investigator i don't think
he's seen anything at this point but i
guess he was like tired of everybody
like bitching at him so he's just like
whatever like do whatever you want
so uh the funny thing about it though is
that emmett seemed to give off the vibe
that he didn't believe that anything
paranormal was going on
but he did say that when they were
bringing in the paranormal investigators
like well you're going to stir some [ __ ]
up and i'm like well do you believe or
don't you yeah because it seemed like he
was kind of saying oh there's no such
thing but then they're like when they
wanted to bring an investigator he's
just like oh you're going to stir up all
the demons it was just gonna i was just
like you know kind of come down on one
side or the other i don't really know
yeah it's got it's got a skeleton it's
got a grim reaper on top yeah like a
little green reaper and like i said it's
round and then there's like little
ravens on the side and [ __ ] like that
yeah um yeah so
then they do like they bring in a medium
who i think's name is betsy actually or
they bring it out to the people they
bring in i wrote it down on the side st
louis spirit search that's what they're
called yeah
so they come in and start investigating
and they pick up some like emf stuff
it's like voices they sound kind of
garbled
um
and then like the medium says that she
feels the presence of like an old man
like standing in the corner and on the
em what did i write e-m-f instead of
e-m-f
yeah okay electromagnetic frequency
reader that's what i'm saying well i
thought that yeah
i was like no like emf like that rave
band from the 90s but that's what i was
thinking but yeah so apparently on the
em the the the voice thing evp is what i
meant today um says this is my house not
like not like the guy from the other
episode but yeah says this is my house
like not in a way like hey get the [ __ ]
out but
hey this is my house like what are you
guys doing in here like you're messing
everything up
now um
she goes into ashley's room that's the
daughter
and says there's a really powerful
negative energy in there
and the medium
betsy thinks that maybe ashley is
causing a poltergeist because like i
said they didn't really go too much into
this angle but
ashley was 13 at the time yeah it's
poultry guys time and she was having a
lot of problems she was skipping school
and she was cutting and so she was
obviously like having some emotional
difficulties yeah so that seems like
prime poltergeist to fodder yeah you
know so i kind of like that the medium
brought that up but they didn't really
go too much into
into that possibility which was kind of
a shame but she did say it
i think that's what she thought i said
earlier it sounded like a poltergeist
that's what she thought it was
so then betsy goes down to the basement
and says oh there's another like entity
down here
and they really don't like us here
they're getting like super super
agitated
and then um
i can't remember this i wrote down betsy
goes into a spiritual vortex and i okay
and i drew this big like spider-man
thing i was just kind of like wow that's
that sounds spiritual serious
so yeah
damn well i mean the way they edited it
i was just kind of like okay as probably
nothing happened but okay that it was
all internal they're just trying to like
make it scary
so steven the original guy that was
running the house he decides he's gonna
research the property and he finds out
there was like a confederate uh slave
owner guy um named captain wilson
who
uh was executed on the property
and then he went on to say that there
was a lot of murders and like other kind
of violence on the property although he
didn't elaborate
and then emmett
the skeptic who was just kind of like
these crazy white women and i don't have
time for this [ __ ]
then no i'm telling you crazy white
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying then he
gets woke up in the middle of the night
and he sees some [ __ ] he sees something
standing at the foot of the bed and he's
like wet in his [ __ ] pants
metaphorically i don't think he
literally sees honky kongs that's what
i'm saying yeah white ghost looking at
him yeah he said it looked like human
like almost human like standing at the
foot of the bed and he was just like oh
no he's like
not having that
and like i said at this point if i was
his wife i'd have been like i [ __ ]
told you [ __ ] why she's like
don't call me crazy oh he was cool he
was cool in the episode though he's like
i've seen it myself i wanted to do this
at least he finally was like i said
that's going right along with the
formula usually it's like the dude never
sees anything and he's just like you
guys you're so crazy yeah you ladies
you're so emotional you don't know how
senses work you don't know eyes work
yeah you don't know how ears work he
jumps out with his tom wait's voice no
i've seen it myself now got like i got
time for this i'm out of here
but yeah like the second he sees
something like his wife is just like
i've been seeing this for like months
and months and you're making me stay
here
you see it one time and you're like
what's get the [ __ ] out of here she's
like god damn it i get it i get it she's
mad
so yeah so then stephen arranges for
like the roman catholics coming because
i guess stephen is like a roman catholic
because there was a lot of that like
about his on his uh website
so um i kind of love this too so he
arranges for a roman catholic priest to
come for a blessing
the roman catholic priest comes in and
they said well
i love the way that they made it seem
like they're like well he came in there
and he seemed like he didn't really want
to stay that long
and we were kind of like making jokes
the whole time because the guy comes in
and he's just kind of like
uh yeah we're blessing the thing bye you
know you know what i mean he was just
like really really
he really didn't do a thorough job let's
put it that way so they're meaning to
imply that he's like kind of like really
bashing comments
because uh thank you tom and jenny
that's great so i'm gonna send so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna send you a
snake pliskin i'm gonna send you uh the
round um
13 o'clock shirt and i'll send you
another 13 o'clock sure it's got me and
jenny on it just make sure that you send
like your mailing address yeah yeah you
think you're interested in something
like my email or in facebook or
something right we got in and where
where did you pay for this i don't know
where you know where was payment sent i
don't know but he must have sent us
payment so yeah we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out we'll look around
for it
so tell me in the comment section where
you sent payment oh [ __ ] we don't i
don't have any extra large blank shirts
in stock so it's going to take probably
about two days to get the shirt yeah
because i got to order some from t
shirts yeah yeah we ran out of edge and
then once i have them all i'll
cut them and i'll ship them out
so it'll probably ship out in about four
or five days
yeah because it usually it takes time i
mean jiffy shirts they usually if you
order them like in the morning it they
usually send [ __ ] the next day right but
we'll see i'll definitely be able to get
it out within five days yeah
because we can send you from the house i
got a scale and then i got to be at your
place a week from now probably yeah oop
uh-oh sex bots sex boxes sex bombs ban
them damn sex bots them sex spots don't
have any titties on them
i don't see anything
if they got boobs they could stay but
they don't have any boobs so get rid of
them
[Laughter]
so yeah so the priest comes in and he's
basically like like amityville horrors
is way out there like yeah i gotta go
bye this like your house is fine it's
blessed blah blah yeah it's all blessed
bye so he does that
so he he gets the [ __ ] out
and then later on either that same night
or shortly afterward um linda is in bed
and she hears like creaky footsteps like
around the bed and then
she said that she felt like something
grabbing her around the neck like
literally like it was strangling her
like she couldn't breathe
so at this point like she calls stephen
because she's not even talking to her
husband anymore because her husband's
just kind of like called her crazy all
the time she's like [ __ ] you i'm just
gonna call this other [ __ ] dude so
she calls steven up and tells him about
it and uh steven is like okay well i'm
gonna come get you i'm gonna get you out
of that house because that place is like
really dangerous
so then when he gets there he said
he found linda on the floor like in the
not in the bedroom but like in the
living room like all bruised and she was
like all like in a fetal position
looking against the wall and basically
was saying like talking about how she
was gonna kill herself
and so she gets sent to a hospital she's
in there for four days like under
observation or whatever
and then the psychiatrist and this is so
funny because we were just talking about
this maybe on yesterday's show or on
last week's i can't remember i think it
was on yesterday's show
um so she gets a psychiatrist to examine
her and the psychiatrist was actually on
the show which doesn't usually happen
now she says okay well
yeah i'm suicidal and yeah like all this
stuff is going on but she's like how
would you feel if i told you my house is
haunted and that's what's causing all of
this stuff like i'm being tormented by a
ghost
and the doctor is a muslim and he
immediately believes her yeah like i
told you guys
and i thought that was so funny because
i was sitting there going yeah why don't
they ever do that and then it's like
this literal show
like the psychiatrist she went to was a
muslim and it's like yeah we believe in
all that [ __ ] and he's like so i she
came in and she was really sincere and i
believed her well they partially cut it
out
but the the islamic doctors like oh yeah
um
belief in spirits and belief in ghosts
demons
and jinn are codified within the koran
so yeah so i told you
don't [ __ ] around with catholics all
right
boy they're just a damn bureaucracy and
you have to be part of the catholic
church for a long time to get any help
from them
if you're not catholic you can't go to
them
with this problem
southern baptists
they're not educated in this
in this they're going to say
everything's a demon and they're going
to try to cast out some kind of [ __ ]
demon like
they're not
they're not trained in this
you're probably better off if you're
going to go to a religious institution
you're probably better off going to a
mosque and trying to find some muslims
and say there's either a gin in this
house
or some kind of ghost
and they'll immediately believe you
[ __ ] you know because
we did a show we did a show on the gym
and we got all the while back a while
back
that was fun made all kinds of friends
in the middle east okay
uh we if one of miss assad he's up in
saudi arabia
and you know i my family has roots in
the middle east they lived there and
worked there my grandfather my mother's
side was was a syrian christian and you
know and
it's just you know i mean the middle
east is a very spiritual place
um
now they're open-minded they're not so
open-minded that their brains fall out
it's just that they know that things
like this exist
you go tell the muslims they're gonna
show up they're going to go okay we're
going to see if there's a gin here
they're going to have [ __ ] there's
probably going to be an imam all kinds
of [ __ ] witnesses you're going to
have people trying to help out oh i want
to see a gin you know
they're at least going to show up and
try to see if something's happening
it's my brain i mean like they're less
likely to give you the run around right
my my advice today is if you're having
any kind of problems like this and you
think you need some kind of spiritual
help
there's a demon or a [ __ ] poltergeist
or a
ghost
i'd go to a mosque
which like i said it's funny that we
brought that up and then the very next
episode which which i totally didn't
remember
um she doesn't like she didn't go to a
mosque but she went to a psychiatrist
who happened to be a muslim right and
then like when she said about her house
being haunted and explained everything
he's like yeah i totally believed her
yeah you know i mean he gave her some
medication and stuff too like to calm
your ass down yeah caveat if you go to a
mosque ask him for help
eventually they're probably gonna
[ __ ] say you need to convert to islam
but that's the way but i mean every
religion they're all religions they're
like they're they're all gonna do it but
islam recognizes christianity
um
these are all in judaism too these are
all
um
[ __ ] uh what do you call them
abrahamic faiths
they kind of have to help you you
believe the same god
so they'll come they just want to see
they are very similar yeah so it's not
like it's not all that right so yeah so
i mean like i said he does give her
medication for depression but i thought
it was kind of cool that he actually
came he actually came on the show and
got interviewed like the actual doctor
and um he's like yeah it's like we we
believe in that kind of stuff so i
didn't think she was crazy or anything
like that he's like yeah i gave her
medication because she was depressed and
everything but you know i i did believe
her about stuff so he's basically like
well um i'm gonna suggest that you
probably move out of that house because
it's probably like not super great
so she is like yeah maybe i should do
that so she moves in with relatives and
then ashley you know gets out of the
hospital she was in the you know mental
hospital for uh cutting and they stay
with the mom and emmett meanwhile
goes to find them a new house
now steven and this is going back to the
whole clown thing because like i said i
thought the clown thing was random but
then at the very end of the show
steven said and the reason that this
episode is called fear house which i
kind of wish they had front loaded with
this information but stephen thinks that
the way that this house works is that it
targets what scares you so his son who
was scared of clowns
um
saw clowns whereas like other people saw
you know was scared of like the monster
in the closet so like [ __ ] would happen
in their closet because it seemed like
different people
in the house like saw different things
or different manifestations so he his
theory was that it was targeting
whatever was like scariest for you
particularly
so that's why so he did actually specify
that his son
who was afraid of clowns had seen murder
clowns in the house because i thought it
was just random that they were showing
that on the show but he's like no
apparently he did see that now uh after
emmett and linda move out
evidently according to the show a family
with six kids jesus christ move in
and only stayed there for six months and
got the [ __ ] out that could mean a lot
of things that doesn't necessarily mean
there was supernatural shenanigans going
on but they just put that in there as a
little thing at the end like you know
saying kind of the thing now here's
something that wasn't on the show
but i thought was kind of like
interesting that stephen wrote
uh in his write-up in 2004.
he said that when they first moved into
the house i think before even anything
like super supernatural had happened
um
he said that everybody in the
neighborhood
would cross the street to not walk in
front of their house
so it seemed like and they noticed it
like the daughter noticed it first he
said but he said they would look out the
window and the daughter be like look dad
like they're crossing the street like in
front of them like coming back and like
walking like that
like everybody knew that the house was
like [ __ ] up and nobody wanted to walk
in front of it i don't know if that's
true or not but i'm just saying that was
like in they didn't put that in the show
but he did say that in his write up and
i'm assuming that's in his book as well
because if you were here earlier
he wrote a book
called i think the first one he wrote
was called the uninvited i think it came
out in 2012 and that was about this
haunting
and i think he wrote a subsequent one
about that too he's writing like books
about other paranormal cases too but i
think he's written two books about this
particular
case
but that was one thing that he said that
all the neighbors seemed to know that
the house there was something wrong with
it and wouldn't like walk in front of it
i'm trying to i'm going through his
little like right up here and looking to
see if there's any i think i mentioned
like how it was always fall yeah
um
screaming in the house yeah
and he said yeah they heard like
screaming all the time
and so there was that
and let's see what else do do do do all
the lights being on yeah he said that
happened a whole bunch of times
and the whole temperature differential
like one room would be warm and then
another one would be freezing cold i've
seen it before so there was that it's
weird though you don't know if it's
actual or just perceived like me and red
would be like is it really cold or we or
do we just think it's cold in here does
it just feel cold it didn't feel normal
whatever it was it wasn't like normal
cold
it was like spiritual cold no way
there's no way to describe it yeah now i
mean in this thing that he said that the
cold actually registered on the thermos
he said it almost and they showed that
on the show too that it said like
because we were going into the
thermostat going maybe we should turn it
up and we're like it shouldn't be cold
in here
you know what i mean [ __ ]
we were confused though i was real young
and so was red at the time
we didn't have a thermometer we just had
a thermostat setting you know the things
you could turn
yeah
we had that bit set at about 70
something and it was cold as [ __ ] but it
was colder in some rooms more than the
others or at least it felt that way and
then other rooms felt fine
it was weird
yeah that seems like what he was here's
another thing too and they didn't put
this in the show but of course like
steven wrote
that he actually saw an apparition
like
he said and this is a quote from what he
wrote he said it was a dark figure of a
man
even though there was full light so i
guess it was like full daylight he was
solid in form except it was a moving
churning dark gray black smoke or mist
that made up his form
and he said he saw this apparition uh
numerous times and that he said too that
every now and then he would go and drive
back by the house and he would see it in
the window like when he drove past so he
said that he saw they didn't put that in
the show but he said that he saw
apparitions so
you know i i don't really know if that's
true or not but that was one thing that
he wrote on there that they didn't put
on the show
so i thought that was kind of
interesting and like i said they didn't
do a lot of the screaming thing he said
one of the main things was
screaming that there was kind of like
uh sounds of people screaming inside the
house all the time like screaming in
pain
and he said that sometimes it was so
loud that you could hear it from outside
and like the dogs in the neighborhood
would bark
um because they heard all this like
screaming so he's implying that maybe
that's why like the neighbors wouldn't
walk by the house because the house was
like screaming all the time and that's
why he called it like the union
screaming house
so like i said as far as i know that's
what it's known as like that's its
official name i guess i don't actually
know where it is the picture or the the
picture that i use for the thumbnail and
like the house that they used on the
show that's
never the house that it actually is
but
if you do a little sleuthing you can
usually figure out where the actual
house is especially if they give their
real names and stuff like that
um but yeah so he he actually did say
that he saw the [ __ ]
ghost and later on when they were
leaving one of the kids said that he saw
what he called the basement monster like
standing in the upstairs window and he
said he turned around and did actually
see that black form like standing up
there in the window like watching them
leave
so like i said
it was like a even though on the show
they showed it kind of like um you know
it kind of escalated and then [ __ ] got
really scary and then they just like
[ __ ] it and they left
in real life at least according to what
he wrote it was like a two-stage event
like they had like some [ __ ] where he
saw apparitions and they were screaming
and stuff and they're like okay let's
get the [ __ ] out of here and then they
stayed at the parents house for a night
and then like the next day or something
like that they came back or they stayed
at the parents house for you know a few
days or a week or something and then
they came back to the house and then
you know
what's the matter what are you calling
me for she's like
come here what's the matter you want to
be on the show everybody wants to see
she wants to be on a ship hello what's
the problem she's trying to get me to do
stuff what's up paul what do you want me
to do what's up
why are you complaining and growling
she's lonely
oh she's like no i'm paying attention
we're going to pay attention we're
paying attention okay we see you she's
like alright enough of that
yeah she probably wants to go over there
and jump on the sink and be like
somebody brush me she's like brush yeah
she's man she has a one track now she's
running she's rolling around [ __ ]
get your toes out of your mouth
it's like having a toddler seriously
she's funny she is like she's a
hilarious cat she's a hilarious cat uh
black frog said there are pictures of
the actual house if so what would i have
to type up to find it not really sure
like look up
union screaming house i'm pretty sure
that's what they're calling it
and
i'm guessing that whatever you get
because he did write a book about the
actual place like i said the house they
used on the on a haunting is not the
real house it never is
but
he wrote a couple books about it so i'm
assuming that you can find the actual
place
i think it's still there but it's in
union missouri that's for sure
it's called he called it the union
screaming house so i would say like
start there because there's a lot of
stuff about that i think it's like some
other paranormal teams have been there
as well like the missouri-based ones
so i'm kind of like looking through his
like i said he wrote kind of a long
thing
um about yeah him seeing the apparition
they didn't put that on the show
and
the neighbors and stuff
and
is that it i think
oh he said that he'd contacted the
landlady they didn't put this on the
show either he said he contacted a
landlady and said did any of the past
tenants like complain about being
haunted and he's like she was kind of
cagey about it oh i can't remember if
anybody said that or not um
she said that one of the
previous female tenants had said that
her dead father came to visit her
but the old woman said yeah i just
thought she was a nut so i didn't really
think about it she said like but a lot
of the previous tenants did leave a lot
of their [ __ ] like in the shed in the
back so there's that
and some people did like kind of leave
just in the middle of the night
but you know it might have been just
because they didn't want to pay rent for
for you guys trying to track down the
houses
most of the time i don't think the house
has a lot to do with it it has more to
do with the people that go into that
house
um
and uh when it comes to the haunting
they never show the real house yeah
but if the if
when when i [ __ ] went tracked down a
haunting in florida this is actually
blackberry said i see it
he found the actual house okay when i
actually tracked down the [ __ ] tried
to track down the house and did track
down the house from a haunting in
florida ed's house the house that they
show in the
on the pro on on the episode is actually
the house on the corner a much nicer
house it's just like down the street
just down the street it's down the
street about four houses
um so it's that same area but it's not
that house
the one yeah the one that it was in was
not that nice okay
similar but not really
yeah yeah and maybe the thing happened
here but i mean the thing about it is
that the house they showed in here was
like a completely decent looking house
and he said from his description
that the house was actually put it was
older like it was a victorian kind of
house but he's like it was way like
bigger and nicer than he was expecting
for the rent rent money
you don't mean so yeah i don't know but
like i said
block park said he saw it
found the actual house okay yeah because
i said he wrote an actual book about it
and it was called the union screaming
house in union missouri so i'm sure you
can find it if you really want to
but like i said
that's i mean i guess that's about it
right i'm looking to see if there's
anything else like significant that was
in his write-up that wasn't actually on
the
show but boogie's biting why are you
biting are you biting daddy don't bite
down she loves to gnaw
why are you gnawing on my hands
she's trying to get me to do stuff
she's like do something you're sitting
here talking to these lights all the
time
it's just it's a program pokey people
are watching us she has no comments
she's like i don't care about that no
one's brushing me or feeding you yeah so
it's um that's it that's pretty much it
yeah
i mean
you hungry yeah okay i'll make up some
meat all right it's dinner time yeah so
yeah so holy crap we've been on for like
an hour and 45 minutes people love this
show though
well this is a lot i don't want to send
some more
it's a lot of fun to do these are a lot
of fun to do they're a lot less
stressful i guess yeah if you enjoyed
the show and you want to send us a super
chat you go ahead and drop one down the
super chat [ __ ] thing and [ __ ]
and um and we'll get some flash bulbs
and it'll all be happy
pookie what are you
doing she's probably trying to get
snacks out of her yeah
she has a little snow why don't you see
if there's any questions or any comments
before we check out i don't see anything
else but uh
you know
okay they're talking about yeah talking
about the clown okay but um
the phrase of the show is black a
lantern
oh yeah yeah he's like a jack-o'-lantern
yeah yeah yeah well i think well
somebody said black jack-o'-lantern and
then i said oh black yeah yeah yeah but
you know what i mean yeah he's cool dude
though man but he's he's like
yeah he was a real character like he was
just on the show i don't know
these white women are crazy y'all crazy
like he didn't say exactly that but
that's what he's talking about that's
what he was thinking white men women in
the ghosts
[Laughter]
yeah that's what i was imagining
you know what i mean but uh but yeah so
okay so tomorrow is wednesday which
means it's our big
like episode show yeah like it matters
really at this point but yeah but we're
doing
another ghost show
because the
the topic that won was haunted bars and
pubs okay so that should be fun thank
you very much thank you thank you thank
you jeffrey jeffrey art satisfied on
jeffy art jeffy art says five dollars
we're gonna be on
y'all keep sending them the long long
[ __ ] we're giving the film a few more
minutes [ __ ] we will be on
yeah so tomorrow night we're gonna be
talking all about haunted bars and pubs
like i said don't
it's there's a lot there's a lot a lot
of ones so i'm really gonna have to like
work hard to like winnow down like the
ones that are most because i've been
like kind of going through lists of them
and be like well is this one that
interesting is that one that interesting
i'm gonna try to like keep it down but
tomorrow i'm gonna have to go and get
some more juice so we can drink
running out of running out of [ __ ]
juice
yeah plenty of vodka we got lots of last
time lots of vodka is this i'm not sure
if this is sad or what yeah but last
time he made a sam's run yeah a week or
two ago yeah and he comes back and he's
like well he i mean he only goes is you
only go to sam's like once every two or
three months right more or less two
months so so he comes back and he says
like three or four huge bottles i had a
i had a fifth of [ __ ] sam's silver
tequila which is great that's what i
mean it's cheap there and it's good so
he's just like oh i got a whole bunch so
we don't have to get back to the liquor
store sam's silver tequila is [ __ ] as
good or better
it tastes just like [ __ ] milagro
silver that's just good and it's only
like [ __ ] 20 bucks it's got a fancy
bottle in there and their big ass thing
of vodka is only 12.99 12.
and i got two of those and it's massive
it's like yeah it's a big and i can't
tell that [ __ ] from gray goose
i can't either no and like i said
sometimes
when i go down because we have a liquor
store just right on the street and if i
buy [ __ ] from that liquor store i'll
usually just get sky which is you know
20 20 25 bucks it's twice the price yeah
so it's twice as much and i can't tell
the difference between sky and between
the sams sam's is better it's like great
goose and it comes in a big huge [ __ ]
um
glass bottle and it's kind of slightly
frosted and then the other one that i
got was sam silver
rum
yeah we got rum tea it's better than
bacardi
better it's almost like i haven't had
bacardi it's like it's like morgan's i
like rum but i just never get it i love
rum
it's like cap morgan silver
silver cat morgan it's like that real
good
[ __ ] sam's is not joking
i'm if whiskey sucked they're [ __ ]
that's the only thing i did get their
whiskey there and it's like i mean we've
talked about that before like the
whiskey wet that that was terrible
terrible it's just like i said it tasted
like licking a barbecue grill it was and
it was you could definitely tell it was
artificial yeah it was very yeah it
tasted like
it tasted like drink it like you know
that artificial smoke stuff yeah that
you feel like the smoke yeah it it kind
of tasted like drinking a bottle of that
yeah terrible to me terrible but every
other thing that we've got there i don't
think i've ever got their gin i wonder
if their gems any good yeah their gin is
good it's like beefuder
did we get their gin before yeah i've
had it before oh we have we didn't buy
it i don't think we bought it but it's
not yeah we usually gin isn't very
versatile you can only do it for [ __ ]
that's true i do like gin but yeah i
don't want to get some
i can get some next time i mean if you
want i'll think about it okay i mean
usually we just i mean usually we just
get vodka because vodka goes with
everything yeah they're vodka you can
get any kind of yeah i can get their
vodka any kind of juice i can get like
zing or tomato juice or anything like
that like everything is good with it
yeah to an extent rum is like that to
you
um and i don't like tequila but you get
tequila but the thing about it is that
sam's
like i said they have all the liquor for
half the price yeah but it's far
you know what i mean so i mean sam's is
kind of like oh every two months you go
and like spend [ __ ] six hundred
members like stocking up for all the
[ __ ] and then like you'll stock up but
for just if we run out of booze we just
run up the street to the liquor store
and then i'm going to have to pay 25.
people out
out of the country like up in europe
sam's is like a different situation
because you have to have a membership to
sam's and really to get those prices
you're supposed to cut i got the
business owners prices and i got that
through my family they they added me
onto their account back when we were in
the horse business
so i'm just renewing that
and that's how i got my sam's [ __ ]
card and it's
bulk [ __ ]
[ __ ] prices are super good
the portions are bigger the prices are
low yeah i mean costco is the same a lot
of costco yeah we have a costco around
here too but i don't i've never been
there they've been going up recently
because of all the supply chain problems
but [ __ ] it's still a lot better than
you get okay like i got a big old thing
of [ __ ] mr butt mrs butterworth
almost like a half gallon of that i
think it was like three and a half three
dollars and fifty cents
for mrs a half a gallon of mrs
butterworth
[ __ ] and we didn't even use a syrup
that i use it i pour it in coffee that's
what i use as coffee creamer oh i didn't
know you were doing that oh no i ain't
[ __ ] suit enough [ __ ] maple syrup
is great in coffee
and
you've been doing all that without me
knowing about it you don't drink it i'll
make you some if you want it's good well
like i said well the thing about it is
that you use the coffee pot downstairs
and i have my own coffee pot in my
office yeah which just makes one cup at
a time yeah no because usually i'll get
up and just make one cup because that's
all i drink usually well sometimes i
make a cup later and like but you never
eat but it just makes one cup
you ever had coffee with um maple syrup
and creamer i have but it's great it is
good it's really good i mean i just
usually make mine with regular ice
creamer like just non-dairy creamer and
sweetened
like you know there's
sometimes a little bit of cinnamon i put
cinnamon in there
but you know me
okay so we can go ahead and shut it down
we're done for the show
xander said i'm a coffee fiend i drink
it all day
you know honestly i do too um
pour some [ __ ] dude pour some uh some
some maybe
yeah it doesn't even have to be real
maple syrup it can be like
cheap maple syrup and it's still like
log cabinets yeah like
they still make log cabins yeah but
that's not that bad uh no i'm saying i
don't know if they still make it mrs
butterworth is the cheapest one oh and
i like mrs butterworth yeah that's the
cheapest one that's what we always had
growing up on the waffle yeah i don't
think it's real maple syrup i think it's
artificial but well no none of that
stuff is it's basically just
corn syrup corn syrup with maple flavor
yeah but you can get real maple syrup
yeah you can uh honestly it's not very
sweet though you know what i've heard
yeah i've heard
that people that are grew up on mrs
butterworth and stuff like that which is
not real maple syrup
they have real maple syrup and they
don't like it yeah it's not that good
it's not very sweet
it's not very sweet and it's thin
yeah it's dinner no you want the fake
[ __ ]
and you pour in like quite a bit of it
don't put a little don't be a [ __ ] pour
in quite a bit of this [ __ ] you look at
the calories it's actually less calories
than sugar
so you put quite a bit in there and your
powdered creamer and pour some [ __ ]
coffee in there man that shit's good
it's addictive it's good on air and
anything
it's great on fried chicken don't be
afraid get this diabetes well i mean i
know that
i've had it on fried chicken before well
honestly i mean fried chicken maple
syrup honey anything that is good on
project yeah come on
you can take
thin sliced pieces or just a big old
here's another thing you can do you can
take the bathroom thank you sebastian
five pounds super chat five pounds bro
thank you very much
you can take five pounds you can take a
hind quarter of a deer
and [ __ ]
paint it up
with maple syrup even if it's fake maple
syrup just hang it
and three days later it'll be cured
if you have if you soaked it in brine
that's even better or roll it in salt
and then just put some [ __ ] maple
syrup on it
go back there three days later and cut a
piece of that off and cook it it's
[ __ ] great really good you can you
can cure and candy meat in
even fake
maple syrup it's great
yeah
well the thing about it it's like i
don't know it's it's not fake anything
it's just fake it's just not really like
out of a maple tree it's not out of the
tree
yeah you know that's all right it kind
of tastes mapley yeah and here's another
thing it doesn't have to be a maple tree
a lot of people think that you got to
get syrup it's got to be in the no you
can do it through birch you can do it
through oak and all kinds of weird you
just got to drive a tap into a tree put
hang a bucket from it and put a little
damn
put a damn roof over it so rain doesn't
get in there and you can sit there and
you can just drain that tree
put water in it later and heat it up and
you'll make any kind of syrup and they
all taste about the same
and you can cure meat with it or pour it
over [ __ ] cakes and make pancakes you
can do anything with it
i make my own show i want to make my own
show about all the survival [ __ ] you can
do with cooking
well the thing about it we thought about
that because remember we started doing
like live streams like called on the
menu and i think we only did five or six
of them five or six years but i covered
a lot of the basics and on the menu but
yeah one of these days you should
probably start it like yeah a cooking
show camp guy said mrs butterworth's is
a top shelf name brand in our house i
mean mrs butterworth's is good good yeah
that's what we usually had at our house
like we had log cabin teeth something i
don't even know if they make that
anymore
but man ooh [ __ ] like somebody i don't
know what i was watching what the [ __ ]
was i watching but somebody like
mentioned i was watching a movie the
other day and somebody mentioned french
toast and i was like [ __ ] man i haven't
had french toast in like years and years
and i was like man that sounds really
good and then zack says ooh chicken and
waffles i [ __ ] love chicken and
waffles and we have a restaurant
in
downtown sanford
called chantelle's we brought it up
before yeah and they have
excellent chicken waffles yeah um
they also have excellent shrimp and
grits yeah man they have like the best
shrimp ingredients in the sherman grits
she's using instead of [ __ ] cream
she's using um
uh coconut milk
coconut milk and cheese velveeta cheese
that shrimp and grits it was like it was
like luscious it was luscious but their
chicken and waffles is really good too
yeah
the thing about it is that the shrimp
and grits because we usually go there
because it's right next to mannequins so
we usually go there like [ __ ] three
in the morning yeah and they only have a
limited menu you can get chicken and
waffles at three in the morning but you
cannot get shrimp and grits at three in
the morning you have to go there in the
daytime he's talking about camp guys
talking about curing bacon inside of
things like
uh maple syrup read it off what does
this say
where where are you looking at the
bottom camp guy
uh i make a beef jerky that has maple
syrup and a sorghum syrup molasses in
the marinade yeah marinade
yeah yeah yeah i mean maple syrup i kind
of feel like people yeah you
that's like really good with bacon like
maple is like a really really good
flavor i think it's underutilized yeah
it's just like a really good like fall
flavor i'm just like man all year long
i'll eat some maple stuff yeah xanada
says he doesn't like grits though he's a
yankee no no you no you got it
it's right i mean it's no different than
like polenta
or you know he's gonna know how to make
them you gotta know how to dress them up
yeah there's another zack saying we have
good comfort food down here yeah it's
not comfort food
when blood people move north
they call it soul food
it's not soul food it's just southern
food
why is it food food it's just southern
[Laughter]
southern whites and southern blacks ate
the same food
pretty much yeah i want chicken and
waffles yeah any difference was any
difference between
southern whites and southern blacks was
family differences family recipe
differences that's the only difference
and you know and there were differences
between the white families and
differences between the black families
of what how they cooked [ __ ] but it's
all southern food southern food is soul
food same thing
when you take southern food and move it
north they call it soul food because
that's more that's more marketable than
southern food because
northern whites hate [ __ ] southern
whites so you can't say southern food oh
i don't want that but soul food oh yeah
yeah yeah we'll eat that you know it's
just politics
politics
camp guy said you don't eat grits plain
you add cheese or bacon or scrambled
eggs or all three yeah or maple syrup or
boil we put
[Music]
and you want you want cheese that melts
real well like velveeta cheese man
that'll that'll sustain you all day
seriously you have a bowl of that with
like eggs and bacon and cheese in there
it's like well that's all i'm eating
today you could put so cold so-called
real cheese in it and melt that too
but you're kind of wasting that cheese
that's expensive cheese cheaper cheese
like velveeta cheese higher in protein
melts a lot easier and it's going to
give you that same flavor
there's a lot of stuff that you can do
you can get powdered cheese like from
the mixes i don't love that though
it's out there it's out there you can
get whole cans of powdered cheese which
is basically the same powder that comes
out of
kraft macaroni and cheese mix you can
buy that
and that's good in in grits but you put
milk
you put milk yeah i don't mind it mixed
into grits in grits i just don't like it
when it's like trying to be like in a
cheese forward after no
i'm not i'm not a fan of it in that it's
good in ramen
if you want cheese yeah you just like
mix it in with ramen or something like
that where it like
this dissolves right then that's okay
big fan of the sex bob thank you very
much but if you're trying to
make it be like actual cheese like in an
omelette or something i'm not a fan
because it's it has like a weird
chemically taste in that application
yeah um xanada said in the north we eat
a lot of casseroles i mean we do too
i ate a lot of casseroles growing up
same kind of thing like because
everybody was into like an easy one-pot
thing where you could just throw
everything into a couch i'm a big fan of
tuna casseroles
i am too honestly i didn't like it when
i was growing up but i developed a i
developed an appreciation because i got
a little bit older using the [ __ ]
cream i mean i could i could take or
leave the peas um
i don't love peas
but so they don't have to be in there
but it's got to be hot though it's got
to be a hot [ __ ] tuna casserole it's
good you said hot peas everything is uh
and then he said uh everything
everything is meat and potatoes in the
midwest yeah i kind of feel like it's
kind of like down the south too i kind
of feel like everything is like meat and
like starch yeah a lot of times it's
potatoes but not necessarily sometimes
rice noodles or rice or rice noodles
various other things mississippi heavy
in rice
yeah yeah
i'm like i said i'm more of a potato and
noodle person i'll eat i i like rice i'm
not saying that because i like a lit
indian food and they eat everything with
rice but yeah if i could pick
i'm usually more into like mashed
potatoes or egg noodles okay so let's go
ahead and shut down jim
i can't believe we've been going for
more than two hours yeah yeah yeah
full blown [ __ ] we need it we need to
eat yeah gotta be and then we need to
watch
coma because that's the movie that's
going up yeah at the end of the day
you're gonna wear that you're gonna wear
that right am i yes i might hit that
you might i might hit that i'm [ __ ]
it's just pulling me in i can't
understand it looking i'm on my
injections you guys i don't eat i can't
get anything done
around here trying to hit i'm trying i'm
trying to like i'm trying to do a show
and i'm just like okay we're doing the
show about this and i have all the i
have all the notes and he's just like
grabbing my i'm just like are you
listening to what i'm saying or hitting
her on the side of a [ __ ] head with
my [ __ ]
like what i'm stressing and i'm just
kind of like waiting for her to finish
and i'm just kind of like are you done
okay yeah yeah
go ahead shut down jenny i'm going to
[ __ ] all right let's make something
so like i said be back tomorrow at 6 00
p.m eastern standard time and we're
gonna do show about haunted bars and
pubs that should be super super fun uh
you know have a drink with us and talk
about haunted [ __ ] and it'll be really
fun so
uh and we'll probably end up talking
about food because you know how that
goes so thank you everybody for dropping
by thank you for your super chats uh
lovely to be hanging out with you on
this haunting monday tuesday and we will
see you guys again tomorrow